GRIFF: UNBELIEVABLE NUMBERS,
BILL MELUGIN.
KEEP IT UP, THANK YOU.
JOINING US NOW TO DISCUSS, FOX
NEWS CONTRIBUTOR TOM HOMAN.
TOM, THANKS FOR TAKING TIME ON
SATURDAY.
LET’S GET RIGHT TO WHAT YOU
HEARD FROM BILL DOWN THERE IN
DEL RIO ABOUT I.C.E., 30% OF
DETAINEES REFUSING TO TAKE IT,
1200 POSITIVE?
>> YEAH.
THEY HAD 1200 IN CUSTODY RIGHT
NOW THAT ARE POSITIVE, BUT
THEY’VE HAD OVER 7500 POSITIVE
CASES RUN THROUGH THE I.C.E.
PROGRAM.
AND THIS IS THE ONES WE’RE
GETTING CUSTODY OF.
MOST OF THESE PEOPLE COMING
ACROSS THE BORDER ARE NOT GOING
INTO I.C.E. CUSTODY.
THEY’RING BEING RELEASED ALL
OVER THE COUNTRY.
AT A TIME WHEN THIS COUNTRY’S
TALKING ABOUT REMASKING, LIKE IN
L.A. THEY’RE TALKING ABOUT DOOR
THE DOOR VACCINATION CHECKS.
THEY WANT TO HOLD AMERICANS
ACCOUNTABLE TO THIS COVID, AND
MEANWHILE WITH THE NORTHERN
BORDER STILL SHUT DOWN, THE
SOUTHERN BORDER’S WIDE OPEN.
OVER 20 CBP OFFICERS HAVE DIED
FROM COVID SINCE WE PUT THEM ON
THE FRONT LINES, THIS
ADMINISTRATION DOESN’T CARE.
GRIFF: TOM, LET ME PUT UP ON THE
SCREEN THE STATS IN THE RGV
SECTOR.
UP 900% INS POSITIVE COVID CASES
AMONG DETAINEES.
135 IN JUST THE FIRST TWO TWO
WEEKS.
THE CHIEF THERE, BRIAN HASTINGS,
SAYS HE CURRENTLY HAS 44 AGENTS
RIGHT NOW THAT ARE POSITIVE, 5
OF WHICH ARE IN THE HOSPITAL AT
THIS MOMENT.
BUT AS YOU ARE FULLY WELL AWARE,
THESE ARE THE FOLKS THAT HAVE
BEEN DETAINED.
WE DON’T KNOW ABOUT THE ONES
THAT ENTERED THAT WERE NOT
APPREHENDED.
SO THE PROBLEM PERHAPS --
>> YES.
GRIFF: -- PERVASIVE.
>> WELL, IT’S PERVASIVE, GRIFF.
THE BORDER PATROL’S ALREADY SAID
APPROXIMATELY 1500 A DAYS CAPE
APPREHENSION.
DAY ESCAPE APPREHENSION.
THESE ARE PEOPLE THAT DON’T WANT
TO BE CAUGHT.
WHY?
BECAUSE THEY’RE CRIMINALS,
THEY’RE DRUG TRAFFICKERS,
THEY’RE TRAFFICKING WOMEN AND
CHILDREN.
THESE ARE PEOPLE THAT DON’T WANT
TO GET CAUGHT BECAUSE THEY KNOW
IF THEY GET CAUGHT BECAUSE OF
WHO THEY ARE, THEY WILL BE
DETAINED.
WHEN YOU SAY A 1500 A DAY,
THERE’S ALREADY 300,000 GOTAWAYS
APPROXIMATELY SINCE BIDEN BECAME
PRESIDENT.
WHO ARE THEY?
WHERE ARE THEY?
ARE THEY WOULD-BE TERRORISTS,
CRIMINALS, DRUG TRAFFICKERS?
WE DON’T KNOW, AND THAT SHOULD
SCARE THE HELL OUT OF EVERY
AMERICAN.
GRIFF: AND WE’RE GETTING SOME OF
THE CRIMINALS, IN FACT IN THE
RGV SECTOR, MORE THAN 1600
CRIMINAL MIGRANTS HAVE BEEN
APPREHENDED.
JUST IN THE PAST 48 HOURS, THREE
MS-13 GANG MEMBERS, KNOWN GANG
MEMBERS, WE KNOW THAT BECAUSE
THEY SELF-IDENTIFY, MANY
CLAIMING CRIMES IN THE --
COMMITTING CRIMES IN THE U.S.,
COMING BACK ACROSS THE BORDER.
AND YOU SAID, TOM, THAT THE
THREAT OF CRIMINAL MIGRANTS IS
GROWING RIGHT NOW.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
BECAUSE THEY KNOW THE BORDER’S
OPEN.
THEY KNOW THAT 40%, 4 OUT OF 10
BORDER AGENTS ARE NO LONGER ON
THE LINES BECAUSE THEY’RE
DEALING WITH THE HUMANITARIAN
CRISIS.
IF THEY CAUGHT THAT MANY, GRIFF,
HOW MANY DIDN’T THEY CATCH?
HOW MANY OF THAT 300,000, YOU
KNOW, WERE CRIMINALS THAT GOT
AWAY?
LOOK, CRIMINALS AND GANG MEMBERS
ALSO EMBED THEMSELVES INTO THIS,
AS A CHILD, AS A PART OF A
FAMILY UNIT BECAUSE WHEN WE DID
OPERATION MATADOR IN NEW YORK
CITY AND LONG ISLAND, WE
ARRESTED 475 GANG MEMBERS,
MOSTLY MS-13.
AND GUESS WHAT?
42% OF THEM, 42%, ENTER THIS
COUNTRY AS AN UNACCOMPANIEDED
ALIEN CHILD OR A FAMILY GROUP.
IT’S JUST NOT WHO GETS AWAY,
IT’S ABOUT THESE FAMILY GROUPS.
THEY’RE NOT WHAT THEY ALWAYS,
PEOPLE ALWAYS THINK THEY ARE.
MANY OF THEM ARE GANG MEMBERS
AND CRIMINALS.
AND 42% OF GANG MEMBERS IS A
HIGH NUMBER.
AND THEY’LL EMBED THEMSELVES IN
THESE GROUPS TO GET RELEASED.
GRIFF: TOM, THIS WEEK IN A TOWN
HALL PRESIDENT BIDEN ADDRESSING
THE SITUATION AT THE BORDER.
HERE’S WHAT HE HAD TO SAY.
>> THERE WERE THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE IN CUSTODY WITH THE
BORDER PATROL.
IT’S NOW CUT BY 90%.
WE’RE -- IT’S CONSIDERABLY DOWN.
GRIFF: CONSIDERABLY DOWN.
DO YOU AGREE?
>> WELL, CONGRATULATIONS,
PRESIDENT BIDEN.
YOU’RE GETTING REAL GOOD AT
RELEASING PEOPLE QUICKLY.
THAT IS WHAT THEY’RE DOING.
YEAH, THERE ARE LESS IN BORDER
PATROL CUSTODY BECAUSE THEY’RE
SENDING THEM TO BUS STATIONS AND
AIRPLANES, PUTTING THEM ACROSS
THE COUNTRY.
I’LL TELL YOU WHAT IT IS, IT’S
AN ENTICEMENT FOR MORE PEOPLE TO
COME TO THE BORDER ILLEGALLY
BECAUSE THEY KNOW THE
GOVERNMENT, U.S. GOVERNMENT
UNDER PRESIDENT BIDEN, WILL BUY
THEM A PLANE TICKET, A BUS
TICKET TO GET THEM TO THEIR
FINAL DESTINATION.
THIS ADMINISTRATION IS COMPLICIT
IN THE ILLEGAL ACTIVITY ON
THE --
GRIFF: TOM, WHY?
WHY?
WHY ARE THEY DOING THIS?
>> BECAUSE IT IS OPEN BORDERS.
THEY DON’T CARE ABOUT THE CRIME,
THEY DON’T CARE ABOUT THE COVID.
THIS IS AN OPEN BORDERS AGENDA.
PRESIDENT BIDEN SOLD HIMSELF OUT
TO THE PROGRESSIVE HEFT TO WIN
THIS ELECTION, AND THE
PROGRESSIVE LEFT IS RUNNING THE
GOVERNMENT.
THEY’RE RUNNING CONGRESS,
THEY’RE AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOMELAND SECURITY AND THE WHITE
HOUSE.
AND THEIR AGENDA IS TO OPEN
THESE BORDERS UP REGARDLESS OF
THE CRIME, THE COVID.
90,000 FENTANYL OVERDOSE DEATHS
ALREADY THIS YEAR, 90% OF THOSE
DRUGS COME ACROSS THE OPEN
SOUTHWEST BORDER ACCORDING TO
THE DEA.
DPRIF GRIFF THE DRUGS ARE A
WHOLE OTHER PART OF THIS CRISIS.
TOM HOMAN, THANKS FOR THE TAKING